un viraje compartido en la lucha contra
las drogas
Ese fue el principal tema de la reunión
del presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
y el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony linquen Petro aprovechó
la primera parada del funcionario
estadounidense en su gira por
latinoamérica para esbozar los puntos en
los que el gobierno de Joe biden podría
apoyar al país uno el incremento de la
capacidad de interdicción
fundamentalmente marítima
complementariamente aérea del país y dos
aumentar la capacidad de inteligencia
para capturar Los Dueños del
narcotráfico en el país el cambio la
política de drogas de Colombia fue
aplaudido por Estados Unidos blinken
aseguró que la integralidad es el punto
clave una que vaya desde la ayuda de los
campesinos para encontrar cultivos
alternativos hasta la reducción del
consumo en Estados Unidos y otros
territorios estamos invirtiendo en la
prevención contra el abuso de sustancias
en el tratamiento y la recuperación para
quienes padecen de adicción en nuestros
países y más allá a pesar de los puntos
en común el encuentro también tuvo
divergencias blinken defendió la
política de extradición mientras que
Petro Busca que aquellas personas que
decían acogerse a la justicia en
Colombia y dar garantías de no
repetición no sean extraditadas las
relaciones con Cuba generaron
discrepancias Petro catalogó de Injusto
que la isla siga siendo considerada como
promotora del terrorismo estatus
defendido por blinken
en cuanto a Venezuela el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos aseguró que
confían que Colombia puede hacer un
puente hacia la generación de un mayor
diálogo democrático en el país una
reunión con la vicepresidenta Francia
Márquez culminó la jornada allí firmaron
el capítulo étnico del acuerdo de paz de
Colombia como un compromiso conjunto
hacia garantizar la representatividad de
líderes comunitarios afrocolombianos
palenqueros e indígenas del país